if your shower's low on hto blame it on
grandpa joe
yeah we're back to restrictions on
shower heads courtesy of present
chowderhead
the bite administration has rolled back
a trump rule allowing more powerful
shower heads but why should he care all
of joe's baths are with sponges
sometimes you never know what what lands
it's enough to make you miss the dude
from before i mean how about the shower
and this beautiful head of hair
but how about the shower
you go into a shower and i have this
beautiful head of hair
you turn on the water drip
drip
drip and water comes dripping out it's
creeping out very
quietly so what do you do you just stand
there longer you take a shower longer
because my hair i don't know about you
but has to be perfect
you know what
america never deserved him
we actually needed a break
for four years for so we can have him
again
yeah under president trump
i know the regulations restricting the
water flow to your shower heads were
relaxed like they took xanax at a james
taylor concert
allowing an increase up to three times
the gallons per minute limit set by the
obama administration but the joke's on
them i'll shower three times longer to
get the soap off but now it's all gone
thanks to the latest shower shakedown i
say keep the government out of my
bedroom and out of my bathroom and out
of the highway rest stops too
[Laughter]
what's the deal joe
look look i'm saving lives all right i i
i got the shower this morning it almost
knocked me over
so
you know
i know a lot about water pressure i was
a lifeguard
okay so don't tell me i defeated corn
pop with nothing but a whistle and two
hairy legs okay
kat um
you announced that you you stopped
bathing as a sign of protest
you smell terrible i might though
honestly because i look i'm just gonna
come right out and say it this is a war
on women why demanding that shower heads
be less powerful and their massaging
capabilities
is a war on women and there's a lot of
ladies out there pretending they don't
know what i'm talking about
just for your back right
whatever you need to tell your husband
so he install it for you
morgan what are your thoughts
i didn't even die yet he's acknowledging
that i'm right
[Laughter]
you're redder than your dress
anyway may have just gotten a new one
myself
well it is the christmas season
is this another example of a great idea
from trump that must be eliminated
because it came from trump so he says we
need to have more powerful shower heads
yes and that's like oh that's just like
um remain in mexico or you know what i
mean it's like all these things that
like totally the same as were made in
mexico
yes it's just as important
i also think it's a war on women because
if the there's nothing worse than having
to wash your hair and i try to get away
with washing my hair like every three or
four days there's nothing worse when
your hair's built up with with you know
like hairspray and someone ew who washes
their hair every day girls don't do that
i watch you wash your hair every day
also on my head it takes forever if
there's not a lot of water pressure it
drives me nuts but i gotta tell you in
addition to the shower head um we should
also check out japanese toilets oh yes i
don't know if you've ever i went to
japan with pompeo and uh the toilet is
also the japanese toilet is also
a good invention oh no no i know what
you're talking about i did it i said
once you go once you go toto
you never go back
that's the brand right it's for the boys
i guess right well no it's just kidding
you can use it jeez i have to be about
genderless i'm totally kidding do you
care about shower pressure i don't have
a shower head i have a pipe that's like
an assault weapon
[Laughter]
but you know everybody knows that you
take the shower head you take out the
restrictors and the washers yeah
definitely do it anyway and by the way
if you do that you can have senator
warren joyrie jumping in the shower
yelling at you why did you do that for
put that back in but you know what
they're going to do next regulate
elephant trunks
wait wait wait what are they doing it
just made me think of troy reid and
senator warren in the shower and i just
did not want to wait i just want to
return to this little tip i you do you
uh take stuff out of the shower yeah you
take the washer around everybody knows
everybody does that i have never i do
not you take it off and you get an
assault weapon in your wall one thing
one thing that i will say about this is
joe biden they're trying to redo
everything that trump did yeah the only
thing that he wants a strong steady
stream of is illegal immigrants flown
across the board
that's all they want good one that's
right that's right i thought you were
gonna go astonishing
strong steady stream in the toilet
with a with you know possessions
you need a strong shower head to drain
the swamp yes
that's what you need i'm kidding and
that's why they don't want them because
they want to elevate this one yeah this
is an amazing topic
you know the thing is about government
encroachment big brother everybody
thinks it's like gonna come in like as
an army no it's always for your own good
they always come into your house and say
no this is for the environment this is
for that that's how you lose your
showerhead
drip drip drip grip you know we should
do whatever business we'll do
pumpkin spice shower heads without the
restrictors and washers next to the 20
percent off of the face thong mask bed
bath and beyond there you go that's the
business i think that i think you just
created a shop for fox nation
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else